well the Iowa caucuses are over and as
expected Donald Trump uh won
overwhelmingly he is effectively the
Republican Presidential nominee at this
point and just like in 2016 Trump is
leading in pretty much every poll in
every state in fact he's uh doing better
this time around than he was in 2016 so
from a historical perspective this is a
unique moment in American politics it's
rare for a former president to run for
office again and uh and also have a
serious chance of winning it's only
having a handful of times in the history
of this country and that that leads to
some shall we say quirks in the process
and here's one of them we're starting to
see the same attacks against Donald
Trump that we first saw all the way back
in
2016 um and even when these attacks make
absolutely no sense eight years later
after we after we saw him in office
they're still trotting them back out you
might remember that in 2016 the big
concern about Donald Trump one of them
anyway was that aside from him according
to the left being a racist and a
transphobe and a sexist and all the
phobes and ists and everything else but
one of the big ones that they brought up
a lot was that uh Donald Trump would
have control over the nuclear codes and
we had to worry about this because
there's no telling what he would do with
the nuclear codes and he might just you
know launch a nuclear attack against a
country because he's having a bad day he
might launch a nuclear attack against
his own country who knows well that's
what they said and needless to say um
just to just review recent history he
got into office and he didn't launch any
nukes actually none at all zero nukes
were launched and now Donald Trump is
back on the ballot and because his
political opponents aren't terribly
creative we're once again hearing a
slightly warmed over version of the old
hits you're not hearing about the
nuclear codes quite as often now but it
we are hearing something similar to that
and this time around instead of warning
about
nukes they're going with something a
little bit more more uh generalized you
know a little more vague and that's
that's where they that's where the left
loves to to live they love to live in an
area that's vague and abstract and can
be interpreted any number of ways so now
they're saying that if Donald Trump wins
in November then he's going to do some
non-specific but also very bad things
with the military could that involve
launching a nuclear attack it could but
it could be anything just something bad
a lot of bad things actually uh this
headline comes to us from NBC News which
as usual is laundering the talking
points of Intel agencies and uh the
defense department quote fears grow that
Trump will use the military in
dictatorial ways if he returns to the
White House well what does that mean uh
well specifically according to NBC News
quote Donald Trump is sparking fears
among those who understand the inner
workings of the Pentagon that he would
convert the nonpartisan US military into
the muscular arm of his political agenda
as he makes commitments or rather
comments about dictator ship and
devalues the checks and balances that
underpin the nation's two Century old
democracy so just to
reiterate um people who understand the
inner workings of the Pentagon are the
Brain Trust behind this
article who are those people well it's
not really clear who they are it could
mean Pentagon officials U could be
retired Pentagon officials it could be
current Pentagon officials um maybe it's
just people who who think about the
Pentagon a lot we don't know they're
just they're people who understand the
inner workings that's all you need to
know and uh and but but that makes them
experts and the NBC news says that we
should trust these Anonymous experts
when they predict that Donald Trump will
convert the non-partisan US military
into the muscular arm of his political
agenda we should just trust them there's
there's a lot to think about here here
and and for one thing um really the
first thing that comes to mind when you
hear about this fear that Donald Trump
will take the nonpartisan military and
make it partisan first thing that comes
to mind is that well the nonpartisan
military doesn't exist so even if Trump
wanted to do that he couldn't because
there is no nonpartisan military to work
with the military is not nonpartisan
anymore and that's why they can't
recruit anyone that's one of the reasons
anyway um they've spent so long
demonizing the lefts enemies white males
specifically for political reasons that
they can't even meet their recruiting
goals
and so it's not nonpartisan but but
despite all that NBC News and the
Pentagon um well no not the Pentagon but
people who understand the inner workings
of the Pentagon want you to believe that
the military is functioning perfectly
right now and it's Donald Trump who's
going to come along and make the
military political and dysfunctional and
he's going to do that we're told by
converting uh the military into an arm
of his political agenda and this is of
course another attack that would have
been can uh fit right in to the 2016
narrative might have been even effective
in 2016 but anyone who's been alive for
the past decade knows that it just
doesn't make any sense now
um and that's because almost every
president in modern history has used the
military to advance their political
agenda and in fact Donald
Trump's perhaps greatest achievement by
far is that he didn't carry on with that
tradition uh he didn't turn Libya into
an open air slave market so that Hillary
Clinton could feel like a strong and
independent woman he didn't invade Iraq
on some phony intelligence about weapons
of mass destruction he didn't pull a
Clinton and bomb Sudan to distract from
a domestic Scandal so I mean really you
can make the case really strong case
that Donald Trump was the single most
restrained president in modern history
when it comes to the use of the
military uh in all four years the only
time Democrats really became upset about
Trump and his use of the military is
when he visited the bombed out church
just outside the White House during the
BLM riots and that's that's the best hit
they had they said Mark Millie uh
shouldn't have been in Trump's Entourage
or something like that and for about
five news Cycles they pretended to be
really outraged by that of course they
didn't care about the BLM riers torching
the church or injuring dozens of police
officers and Secret Service agents they
didn't care about that they were laser
fol focused on this one incident because
it's the only example they could think
of to make the case that Donald Trump
had somehow co-opted the military to
serve his own political
ends um but again there are many real
cases of recent presence in this country
in fact every single recent president
doing exactly that and Donald Trump was
the one guy who didn't but they have to
lie about this just like they lied about
the nuclear codes in 2016 and the reason
for the lie is the same just like in
2016 the point of the slander is to
delegitimize the Trump Administration
and lay the groundwork for undermining
it from
within eight years ago all the warnings
about Trump's instability and nuclear
codes and so on gave the FBI an
important pretext to launch an
indefinite investigation into his
campaign and uh we know how that turned
out if you convince millions of
Americans that Donald Trump wants to be
a dictator a willing servant of
Putin then it's a lot easier to justify
illegal wiretaps of his campaign and
everything else they did the only
difference is that back in 2016 nobody
admitted any of this out loud like
nobody came out and said that they were
actively working to undermine his
authority and now they're just coming
out and saying it quoting from the NBC
news article now bracing for Trump's
potential return a loose-knit network of
public interest groups and lawmakers is
quietly devising plans to try to foil
any efforts to expand Presidential Power
which could include pressuring the
military to cater to his political
needs
now if you're wondering what an
Insurrection or a coup looks like well
it looks exactly like that I mean and
the media is openly bragging about
they're openly bragging about a deep
State plot to usurp the president's
Authority the article goes on to explain
that quote those taking part in the
effort told NBC news that they are
studying Trump's past actions in 2024
policy positions positions so that they
will be ready if he wins in November the
that involves a preparing to take legal
action and send letters to Trump and
appointees spelling out consequences
they'd face if they undermine
constitutional
Norms because you know there's nothing
these people care more about than
constitutional Norms of course so a
bunch of leftwing activist groups are
going to threaten Trump um and threaten
Trump appointees if they undermine quote
unquote constitutional Norms which are
you know what are the Norms well those
are the Norms as they are defined by
these left-wing activist groups the
leftwing activist groups will tell us
what is constitutionally normal and if
you venture outside of that then you
should be in prison that's the general
approach what would be interesting to
know is um how many of these activist
groups ever threaten the Biden
Administration you know when the when
the White
House nationalized the rental properties
or tried to force millions of people to
take the co shot or tried to implement a
mask mandate on airplanes even though
all available sign said it was
ridiculous uh did any of these Defenders
of constitutional Norms have any issue
with
that no of course they didn't now in
this article NBC News is careful um not
to admit too much you know they're
saying that the Deep state is just going
to file lawsuits and send letters but I
mean everyone knows that's not all
they're going to do at multiple points
during the Trump Administration career
officials and defense department and
intelligence agencies um openly defied
the president and
subverted his authority as Jonathan Swan
and Zachary bassu reported for axio
quote once in office Trump's Ambitions
to withdraw from Afghanistan and other
countries were subdued slow rolled and
detoured by military
leaders now to give one example in the
case of Syria um officials routinely
lied to Donald Trump about the number of
troops in the country which is something
much more serious and direct than
sending letters and filing lawsuits Jim
Jeff the former US Envoy to Syria stated
in an interview that quote we were
always playing Shell Games to not make
clear to our leadership how many troops
we had
there and he said that in reality the US
had a the US had a lot more than the 200
troops in Northern Syria which Trump had
agreed
to and and they lied to him and those
are that's like a direct quote it's a
trump Administration official admitting
that they all just lied to the
commander-in-chief about troop levels in
Syria
because they wanted to undermine his his
actual constitutional Authority you know
when you're running a business time is
money that's why I'm so excited to have
ramp as a new sponsor for my show if
you're a uh a finance professional
looking for a better way to maximize
productivity and cut wasteful spending
than ramp could be for you ramp is the
corporate card and spend management
software designed to help you save time
and put money back in your pocket with
ramp you can issue cards to every
employee with limits and restrictions
Auto um automate expense reporting and
stop wasting time at the end of every
month ramps accounting software
automatically collects receipts and
categorizes your expenses in real time
so you don't have to you'll never have
to chase down a receipt again and your
employees will no longer spend hours
submitting expense reports the time
you'll save each month on employee
expenses will allow you to close your
books eight times faster ramp is easy to
use get started in less than 15 minutes
whether you have five employees or
$5,000 get $250 when you join ramp just
go to ramp.com Walsh spelled
rm.com Walsh again that's ramp.com Walsh
cards issued by Sutton Bank and Celtic
Bank members FDIC uh terms and
conditions apply now keep in mind Donald
Trump publicly ordered a full pull out
from northern Syria and there were there
were a bunch of Articles documenting
this but Jeffrey and the Pentagon just
ignored it as Jeffrey put a quote what
what Syria withdraw there was never a
Syria
withdraw because they were just going to
ignore him now call it the Deep State uh
call it whatever you want these people
conspired to prevent Donald Trump from
governing and then they they gloated
about it and this happened again and
again at one point the New York Times
played um played up this uh you may
remember this oped from an anonymous
Trump official saying that there's a
quote resistance moving movement against
uh Trump that was operating within the
federal government that's where the
whole we started hearing all this
cringey stuff about uh the resistance
and that's where it came from except it
came from someone who was supposedly
inside the White House quote like-minded
colleagues and I have vowed to thwart
parts of his agenda and his worst
inclinations according to the official
and leftists absolutely love that they
also loved it when Mark Millie pledged
to warn the Chinese government if Donald
Trump ever ordered an attack that would
affect Chinese
interests which last I checked as
treason
I mean it's among the most OB it's not
just treason it's one among the most
obvious you know cases of treason that
you can imagine the chairman of the
Joint Chiefs of Staff tipping off an
adversary about possible US military
action I mean
that's you you you literally don't get
more treasonous than
that but again the media and Democrats
celebrated
it so what these career operatives did
is far more akin to dictatorship I mean
far more than anything Trump ever did
because America for one thing Americans
elected Trump nobody elected these
people uh no one gave them the authority
to keep US troops and countries when the
president wanted them
gone nobody gave them authority to
thwart everything Donald Trump attempted
to
do uh and and and when he was acting on
the agenda that he that he ran on so
this is what the voters wanted and
you're supposed to care about that if
you care about democracy they just went
ahead and and sabotaged him again and
again they kept subverting the will of
the democratically elected
president it's what happened when Trump
cut off uh weapon shipments to Ukraine
which naturally angered the weapons
manufacturers there was testimony at
Trump's first impeachment hearing that
the defense industry began flooding the
Pentagon with phone calls shortly after
the Trump Administration suggested it
would cut off these weapon shipments and
what do you know within weeks the CIA
operative in the White House whose name
you were never allowed to know leaked a
classifi ified call to Adam Schiff and
kickstarted an impeachment and that's
the phone call where Trump made the
mistake of mentioning the Biden family's
corruption in Ukraine and uh yet again
none of these Defenders of democracy who
are so upset about a second Trump term
said a word about any of
this and that's because they're planning
to do it again and that's why the media
will again paint Trump as a dictator so
that they can prevent him from governing
last night as the Iowa caucus results
came in uh there were many media members
that were on
TV pushing this narrative against Rachel
madal was was one of them watch the big
picture takeaway from that and I don't
mean to be again too dark as you said on
this but it is not if we are worried
about the rise of authoritarianism in
this country we are worried about
potential rise of fascism in this
country we're worried about our
democracy falling to an authoritarian
and potentially fascist form of
government the leader who is trying to
do that is part of that equation MH but
people wanting that is a much bigger
part of that equation and the American
electorate is made up of two major
parties one of those parties has been
flirting with extremism on the ultra
right for a very long time they've
brought them in in a way that they
haven't been Central to Republican
electoral politics ever before and I
know because I've been studying this but
once you have radicalized one major
party so that those are the preferences
of the people who adhere to your party
the leaders
interchangeable as a side note clip is U
interesting it's one of the rare
instances of Rachel mattow and Chris
Hayes being spotted in the same room at
the same time and for you know sometimes
it's not clear if Chris Hayes is just
Rachel mattow in drag or vice versa you
really we really don't know but um
anyway they're they're there together
and as for what Rachel mattow said of
course she's just further advancing the
corporate messaging of NBC News she
wants NBC viewers to think that
authoritarianism is coming and so to
prevent it we need to imprison Donald
Trump and kick him off the ballot
because if you're worried about
authoritarianism the best way to prevent
that is to imprison the top political
rival of uh your of your favorite
politician you know of your guy like
that's that's how you prevent
authoritarianism and of course this was
never a compelling argument but it's
especially unconvincing after Trump has
already served as president for a whole
term and and during that
term as Ronda sandz has correctly noted
as I've said many
times um far from being a dictator
Trump's problem when he was in office
was exactly the opposite of that it was
exactly the opposite of being
authoritarian Trump in fact was as far
on the other end of that scale as you
can
be he was way too far on that end of it
because if anything Donald Trump was
reluctant to use his power he didn't
wield his authority in situ situations
where it was necessary and would have
been perfectly legal to do so he didn't
even fire Tony fouchy for completely
botching the covid
response um and and and you know when
when if you ask him why he didn't fire
him he'll tell you that it's because he
didn't want the media to be mad at him
so that that's not what a dictator says
that's not how a dictator
behaves and that's how non dictatorial
he was to his
detriment now at some level it's clear
that these propagandists are aware of
how flimsy their case is that's why last
night for the most part they didn't
allow their viewers to see uh or hear
Donald Trump's victory speech I mean
this is the presidential front runner
who just won the Iowa
caucuses you're a news channel this
matter how you feel about it this is
this is news it's the biggest thing
happening in politics right now but CNN
cut away from Trump's speech the moment
he began talking about the southern
border msbc made a big show of of hiding
the footage from their viewers watch um
at this point in the evening the
projected winner of the Iowa caucuses um
has just started giving his victory
speech uh we will keep an eye on that as
it happens uh we will let you know if
there's any news made in that speech if
there's anything noteworthy something
substantive and important um the reason
I'm saying this is of course there is a
reason that we and other news
organizations have generally stopped
giving an unfiltered live platform to
remarks by former president trump it is
not out of spite it is not a decision
that we relish it is a decision that we
regularly
revisit um and honestly earnestly it is
not an easy decision but there is a cost
to us as a news organization of
knowingly broadcasting untrue things
that is a fundamental truth of our
business and who we are and so his
remarks tonight will not air here live
we will monitor them um and let you know
about any news that he makes now you
notice that you can't even mention
Donald Trump's name at first right it's
the whole Voldemort thing she's she's uh
she refers to him as the winner of the
Iowa
caucuses and then she lectures her
viewers about how important it is to to
muzzle him she appears to claim with a
straight face that
MSNBC might be sued if they air the
victory speech of the presidential front
runner and by the way if that's true
which which it's not um any real
journalist would welcome that
lawsuit I mean that's that that's you'll
win that lawsuit in 45 seconds but
nobody NBC is pretending that they're
real journalists anymore and uh again
this is all right out in the open
now so it's pretty clear after last
night that the corporate press and their
allies and intelligence agencies um
aren't going to change their strategy
but it's also clear by extension that if
Donald Trump wants any chance of
actually governing this
country he's going to have to change his
strategy and his
approach um he's going to have to
command the military instead of allowing
the military to command him he's going
to have to get rid of the prosecutors
and the bureaucrats who spent the last
four years trying to imprison his
supporters and do things even worse than
that he's going to have to stop making
any effort to to try to get these people
to like
him whether these are the people of the
New York Times or NBC or anywhere
else he's going to have to embrace being
hated by
them which shouldn't be hard to do
because you have no choice
anyway if Donald Trump becomes president
after last night's results in Iowa it's
looking more and more likely then he
only has one
option not that he should become a
dictator but that he should actually
wield his lawful power and do it
effectively and
ruthlessly to advance the agenda that
he's running on and that if he's elected
he will be elected to advance
which means that in that
way this time around he's going to have
to give these fear-mongers precisely
what they
fear if You' like to see what else I
have to say you can access my full show
by going to dailywire.com or by going to
the Matt wall Show Twitter page hope to
see you there God speed